today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the china virus that
will
save countless lives
convalescent
from the flows of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
[Music]
today i'm convalescence to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
[Music]
convalescence
bigger and better and stronger
bigger and better and stronger
nasty guy who can't get along with
anybody
all right welcome everybody it is the
weekend it is
um the first stream back from our one
week off
i think i received um
how many was it i think i got about 45
emails this vacation from people saying
david
your website's all messed up
everything's wrong
you're linking to the wrong episodes is
the show over
get it together and of course we were
just on vacation just reruns
everything's fine you know no matter i
mean i think i
it's probably good that we were able to
get the number of emails like that
down to 45 because often it's uh
up in the hundreds so it was just a
vacation week
popped on did a couple of streams sort
of in the middle of it but
um what what a major major 24 hours of
course
uh highlighted by the tragic tragic news
on a personal level and tragic news
politically um for those in favor of
logic
reason sanity and democracy the passing
passing of supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg we learned about it last
night
and the um sort of cultural implications
are significant ruth bader ginsburg with
a very interesting past
from brooklyn new york uh growing up
uh as a young jewish woman in new york
city
in the early into the mid 20th century
and everything that she accomplished and
everything that she represents and
all of that right that that is enough
for hours of programming in and of
itself
and then we get to as i said yesterday
on on twitter as some of you may have
seen
um donald trump will now have the
opportunity
to screw the country not just for four
years
not merely for eight years but for
decades
and of course i referenced immediately
mitch mcconnell's statement from 2016
when judge antonin scalia died and
barack obama nominated merrick garland
you don't confirm supreme court justices
during the last year of a presidential
term
you let the voters have a say democrats
have to keep mitch mcconnell to his word
that was from 2016. now if you're
wondering
how are they going to get some kind of
philosophical black hole or how will
they justify
what is obviously going to be what
donald trump tries to do
which is likely nominate a replacement
for ruth bader ginsburg in the next two
weeks
and try to squeeze it in before the
election although more likely
they would try to squeeze it in between
the election and inauguration day
even if joe biden wins and that will be
a fight um
what what we have to understand is they
already have their explanation and their
explanation is i hope you're sitting
down for this one okay mitch mcconnell
in his in the letter he wrote last night
and i'm kind of winging it today you
know i didn't i don't have the letter to
show you but you can find it
in the letter that the office of mitch
mcconnell put out yesterday they were
saying well listen
in 2016 it was opposite
party it was democratic president
in his last year with a republican
senate
this is a totally different situation
because it's a republican president and
a republican senate so
we're just going to go ahead and uh and
and
nominate a replacement now can they
actually get it done
unclear there were early rumors
yesterday that
willard mitt romney also known as
mitt romney or mittens
willard mittens to some there were
rumors that
he said he would not vote until there's
an election
uh and and depending on the outcome
until after the inauguration his office
immediately said that's not he's not
said that now
it doesn't mean that it's wrong it's
just that he had not yet said it i think
it was sort of
some motivated speculation we do have
lisa murkowski
just prior to the passing of ruth bader
ginsburg saying
uh fair is fair and she would not be
inclined listen we're gonna have to see
is the point we don't really know right
now what it is that
uh that that how that how that's going
to go we're going to have to wait and
see
um so today we are
expecting donald trump at the top of the
hour in
fayetteville north carolina right now
this completely whacked
channel called right side broadcasting
is live
the official trump youtube channel is
not yet live
fox news is not yet live so we're we're
going to have to kind of keep an eye on
this right side broadcasting if you can
imagine something more toxic
but we are awaiting the landing of
donald trump's plane
and of course as you can see no to very
few masks in sight
uh donald trump previously demanding
that north carolina be opened it is open
and um you know it's it's gonna be a
whacked evening and we don't know
to what extent donald trump will discuss
the passing of ruth bader ginsburg and
what is obviously his plan
to try to fill that seat and fill that
seat very very soon
um but we will see what he has to say
coming up
very very soon let me get to a few
super chats that are coming there's a
lot happening i know i've been away and
people are
itching itching scratching to get back
in
um let me first just do twitch because
it's quick
we're sadly down back into the triple
digits for twitch subs because as you
know they expire monthly so we're down
to 9.77
but thanks to one bite and circle hair
guy
and silent night we're pushing
pushing back we're churning these
numbers we're we're sauteing these uh
subscriber numbers and going to ramp
them up very soon
cuabiriez has subscribed with prime and
says assume trump confirms a new judge
then biden wins what are your thoughts
on the likelihood of packing the court
yeah i i am still thinking through
the uh political implications of it
but i think that it needs to be made
clear to republicans that if they do
this
it is a huge risk if trump loses that
then there is a completely wide open
door to pack the court and i would very
powerfully
look into that uh and and likely support
it even though i've been cautious about
it in the past
listen i am likely to completely lose my
mind
if uh republicans are able to do this
and i might
i might say get rid of the filibuster
pack the court
uh rip it all off of the walls
if that uh if if that were to take place
all right
we have just triggered a hype train on
twitch
let's get that going i'm going to check
back in with twitch momentarily
but i do have some super chats that i
want to read as we await the arrival of
uh
one of donald trump's many planes
chakuseki
has checked in with a super chat and
says dave can you give a shout out to my
homies
spencer the hutt yo-yo modi and
vaz the crazy bus thanks there it is
shout out to the three of you
love it marika says hey david thanks for
streaming during the weekend
rbg is huge news absolutely
absolutely i had to be here for it kyle
hopper says aoc's message last night was
excellent you'll dig i have not yet
seen it but i will look into it um
joseph dinsey's says rbg passed
passed away on rosh hashanah making her
a sadiq a righteous one i think we
should look at the bright side this will
energize
the progressive base to get out the vote
donate and campaign
i love that joseph brings this up and uh
yeah keep the super chats coming that's
a great way to uh to participate
um i actually think that
although this is not a stable country
right now
this is this is a very uns unstable
country as many of you know
but if there is one thing that i can be
relatively certain about
it's that the possibility that donald
trump gets
in his last for in the 45 days
remaining before the election or in the
last
four months yes four months almost to
the day of his of his uh term
that he may put a supreme court justice
in this is going to
help the turnout for people
who will not vote for donald trump and
will vote for joe biden i am certain of
it now
the degree to which that will happen i
don't know
but this will energize people remember
those clowns in 2016.
i know you know them there were lots of
them on the right but there were some on
the left
who were saying trump or hillary they're
both part of the same establishment
i don't care which way because it's all
the same and people stayed home
and it was out of your mind idiotic
i think that there are some of those
people
who are going to see this and say oh oh
hell no
now i need to vote it may not even work
to stop
trump from appointing someone i think if
trump appoints someone and gets them
confirmed
it will even more bolster uh turnout
for joe biden so i think that that
that's a reality and we'll talk
upcoming about the degree to which
um that will be a thing uh
and people are pointing out that some of
those people are in my audience yeah i
mean listen we they're they're
every you know my audience has
everything from uh you know anti
semites anti yo semonites who write to
me all the time
all the way to marx's socialists
anarcho-capitalists and
there's everything in my audience and
we're gonna follow that very very
closely
thank you to so many people who have us
on a level three hype train right now
let's do it let's at least
get back up to a thousand subs on twitch
mootbar predacon jalarsen
typical college stud grungy dan
the phony pope fatty mcblunt's
donkey show microactive all of these
great people participating
and uh i think it is conceivable i think
it's conceivable
that we could have a successful five
level uh hype train today
other super chats continuing to come in
they are accelerating i want to hear
from you
let's can we get off of this toxic
channel is anybody else live yet yeah
okay good all right so some somebody
else is live now
we imagine having to go to fox news
to have a less toxic stream
okay that tells you how bad things are
steven says 6-3 conservative majority
for decades
suck it even if trump loses you're all
behind for decades goodbye roe v wade
taste the victory libs stephen i hope
that was worth five dollars for you
thank you for supporting my program
matthew paul says i'm so bummed that
people are choosing this guy
it is sad dylan clutter
has subscribed over on uh
youtube sunil wani says this hypocrisy
is through the roof thanks for getting
us all through this mr pacman and
congrats on 1 million
thank you tristan mccoppen says
with amount of power corruption and
opportunity trump and republicans have
i don't see them him allowing an
election
loss what do you think yeah i mean
that's that's certainly
you know we're we're we're exploring
that in our coverage of election
foul play we certainly are we are now on
a level
four hype train over on twitch thanks to
cho
ben for subscribing with twitch prime
we do now have um we actually have
i'm trying to think now for i believe
some 14
month subscribers on twitch
which is wild caitlyn campanella
dietrich dietrich says can you explain
abolishing the filibuster
yes but not right now i want to be fully
prepared with the history of it and
we'll do a segment on that
uh very very soon thanks to kathleen
babcock kathleen is new member number
one
today at joinpackman.com very much
appreciate that
i uh listen i i don't
i don't want to be too forward but i
would suggest
uh joining kathleen at joinedpakman.com
why not
a brody andrew mulligan says today we
grieve tomorrow we grind
register remind and remove trump from
the white house
people in the future need us today now
love from texas
absolutely well said brody chris says
glenn kirschner made a video on rbg
can recommend thank you
bronx bjorn says just donated
50 to biden always loved bernie but
never donated to him
rbg death was a wake-up call for me
elections truly have consequences well
said
well said thanks to zynga
for the twitch sub also thanks to david
bayer
for the twitch sub appreciate that
chakaseki
says i predict trump will brag about
packing ramming the court with
conservative judges kind of like how he
packs rams and crams
his maw with kfc attendees
yeah i think now he's more into uh was
it burritos what was he what was he
pictured eating lately it was vile but
it was
not the food just trump trump going oh
no it was a philly cheesesteak on air
force one
uh thank you to 14194 you me
for the subscription nerd shaman has
subscribed and has pushed us
into a level five hype train kitty
shook kitty shook has subscribed on
twitch
and uh thanks hannibal for the support
as well
very exciting who else do we have here
azeem abu khalil says did mcconnell's
blocking of obama's supreme court pick
in 2016
constitute a constitutional violation
i don't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter that's one of those questions
where it's like
yeah maybe maybe but um
it's not going to uh we we've got to
remember
what we what we have to do is remove
them now let's stay focused on that
what recourse do we have in 2020 yeah
basically none
basically none rest in peace rbg
well said well said
uh big thank you to jordan longoria
jordan longoria is new member number two
today on my website
joinpakman.com i appreciate that if
you're just joining us
vacation is over we've got we you know
before our vacation
i said we're taking this week off and
then we're coming back
and then we've got a lot of work to do
we've got the debates starting
not this tuesday but the next one vp
debate
campaign election meddling whatever
happens we've got lame duck to
inauguration
we're we've got a lot ahead of us we've
now added to that
the tragic death of ruth bader ginsburg
and the political fight
that that is going to represent so we
have our
work cut out for us i hope you'll be
here with me
we're going to be here let's see here
uh dantastic says heartbroken over rbg
i hope they get a lot of backlash from
murdering someone
for free the double standards that
mcconnell has
is has his infuriating it is infuriating
certainly no doubt about it dylan
clutter says i posted a video on the
subreddit
of someone who i work with getting
interviewed we look like idiots
recommend you watch for a good laugh
okay we will check that out jamie says
trump is so dumb that he would probably
benefit from holding off on a scotus
pick whoa where'd it go
would benefit from holding off on a
scottish pick he can campaign on that
and bump the turnout for gop voters
i actually read something that that
suggested if trump nominated merrick
garland
he almost certainly wins reelection
because that might appeal to
the trump clowns will support anything
he does and there might be some people
who now are like oh no no no
i've got to get out and vote if trump's
going to ram someone through
and then they hear oh he nominated the
guy obama was going to put in
maybe maybe that helps trump i think
that's a fair point
rob yale says just 10
sends the number 10. thank you we do
have
about a minute and a half left to
complete a level 5 hype train
over on twitch i want to say thanks to
vajoo who has subscribed with prime and
the message hey david keep the faith
and shel marley has also subscribed i
very much
appreciate that um
okay what else do we have going on
um oh there's some other new members
hold on
matthew connor is new member number
three matthew drangler
is new member number four elijah nav
zigger
is new member number five chantal
boucher
is new member number six and bonnie
nelligan is new member number seven
today at joinpakman.com thanks very much
i appreciate that
uh if you are just joining us this uh
rally
in fayetteville north carolina where the
virus will be spread
and stupid things will be said
uh is in fayetteville north carolina
scheduled for 6 p.m eastern time just
one minute from now we're standing by
waiting for the arrival of donald trump
we have successfully completed a level 5
hype train on twitch we've not had a
successful one for weeks
for weeks so i very much appreciate that
love it love it love it and remember
that if you are watching on youtube
the fight doesn't stop at a million we
are
working on 1.1 million
subscribers and i would love it if
you're watching on youtube for you to
hit that subscribe
button other super chat oh people recent
polling yeah let's look at that
actually before we even do that i have
one fresh meme for you guys today
this is another deep fake this is
sam cedar trying to sneak into the
million subscriber club and i confront
him okay this is another one of those
deep fakes
there i am hey brain
what are you doing here that there it is
all right so that's me confronting sam
cedar
um and as far as recent polls go
so i i wanted to mention a couple things
listen the the polls can change
and the polls could be very wrong okay
certainly those are possibilities but
they're not looking good for donald
trump right now and i had some people
email me about this poll
that says david everything's fine look
at missouri
okay trump's up by eight in missouri
trump won missouri in 2016 by 19 points
if this is true and trump wins missouri
by eight
it's very bad for trump i think that
there's a lot of people who are
there's healthy skepticism of the value
of polls
and the accuracy of polls and then
there's just
kind of idiotic confusion okay if
in 2016 trump won missouri by 19
and he's only winning by eight right now
and you can believe this poll which
as far as i know we can that is a loss
of 11 points for trump
in missouri okay that's not good for him
now
of course the polls could be wrong voter
suppression isn't in here
it's all of course but like this this
isn't good winning by eight
isn't good you know i got people who
said where was this other one
trump's winning utah by 18. look at that
remember that in 2016 there was a strong
um
uh third there was a strong evan
mcmullen i think he was third party
um or independent in utah and
we don't so the okay utah is one of the
most conservative states in the country
so what trump plus 18 in utah tells us
what it tells us nothing tells us
nothing it's
the election is not coming down to utah
so all of this stuff could be very wrong
very bad we could all end up devastated
on november 4th of course um but
people you know let's understand what's
going on here please please
okay brooks madden says
imagine a lame duck trump now that's
scary yes yes i've talked about that
uh many times and that is very scary
also
i can consider this
scary lame duck trump scary
lame-duck trump supporters with guns
who believe that it was rigged and that
that's why trump lost
that's the scenario that is very very
scary
for me very very scary for me thanks to
mr cool dad for subscribing with twitch
prime
as well as luch wango
sourdee jay gator hunter
optical monk erica a.t
james gentry oh the serfs
the serfs foe six
pyro's unicorn and so on and so forth i
mean there's just so many people here
andre bavaria says thanks for doing what
you do
this election is important for the whole
world reason decency humanity truth
democracy education have to win
following from germany if only i could
vote blue thanks andre
uh i would love to visit bavaria i've
never had the pleasure but i am told
that it is an amazing amazing
place hopefully soon hopefully soon
someday
okay other super chats ant and sharon
the bottom say hey pack we watch all the
time thanks for all the info
big love and support hashtag the bottom
suicide awareness thank you
zachary monroe says via youtube
super chat it's so hard being the only
liberal
in a highly conservative family rest in
peace ginsburg
congratulations on reaching 1 million
subscribers love
the show thank you tiffany lupardus
says there is only one planned
parenthood in missouri
we need to stop him at all cost
joey two times says the minority
has too much control over
the majority dt
says if the vacancy isn't filled before
november what happens if there's an
election
legal battle that is also a very
relevant
and important question no doubt about it
uh and i'm a lot of these things i want
to devote you know a little more thought
to
and they will be covered on the monday
show now that we are back from uh
back from vacation thanks to devastate
as you can see up there for subscribing
with twitch prime raising a glass to
devastate
uh give me our milk please has
subscribed and says hi
big fan but doesn't matter everyone
needs to go and vote
absolutely absolutely
um okay what else do we have
here uh oh people asking
yeah i mentioned that during my vacation
i was um
re-watching some breaking bad i got into
season
two and right now
it's j i'm just past where
okay listen this is an old series so
there's going to be spoilers spoilers
spoilers
turn it off if you still haven't seen
breaking bad and don't want it spoiled
i'm about to talk about what happens in
season two of breaking bad which is like
12 years old
spoilers are coming spoilers are coming
i just got
past where uh tuko dies
so that's where that's where i am
kind of a little too much of a lead up
there before uh
just saying that spoilers here we go
desiree says thank you david you helped
me get these
political tough times thank you
michael kearns with the biggest super
chat of the day so far
at 20 us dollars that's the greenback my
friends
david congrats on 1 million well
deserved mate you're one of the best
hosts ever
wonderfully neutral yet morally grounded
i i am flattered thanks michael
donna williams says david i joined when
you covered solimani
and trump went to sleep thank you for
your thoughtful coverage as
always thank you i appreciate that ethan
demillo
says what do you think the chances are
of the vacancy being filled before the
election
i think the chances of before the
election are five percent
um i i think the real risk is during the
lame duck period
if trump wins it's like fill it whenever
right because if it's
yeah he's gonna get to fill it if trump
loses
filling it during the uh lame duck
period
is scary that's very scary okay other
members that i want to say thank you to
christoph richter is new member number
eight
laura siaka is number nine
gabriel carby is number ten jill hoffman
is number 11. that's 11 at
joinpackman.com
appreciate it um this was scheduled for
seven minutes ago donald trump has not
even landed yet as many of you can
probably notice
let's see what is going on over on the
trump youtube channel
nothing and on right side broadcasting
they're still promoting
future rallies and events one would
imagine
that the landing of the plane is going
to happen very soon
yeah let's see is there audio here let's
see
is that religious music my god what is
going on there
okay michael grace says
obama was blocked whoops i lost it hold
on let me find that
uh where did that okay here it is
obama was blocked from nominating a
judge
how many other presidents have been
blocked from nominating
if you don't know offhand you can cover
this
um yeah i'm not aware of obama being
blocked from nominating
no but i will look into it christ
illusion says decided to turn republican
because the system is set up for me
straight white mail
just sad day weird okay
evan williams says does it annoy you how
much of trump's antics get ignored by
the mainstream media
yes chamath rathnayaker
says far right brown dude here
supporting biden
against war-mongering trump-free
palestine okay
shad price has signed up submarine nick
says david thanks for bringing
sanity into the world do you think some
of the republicans at risk of losing
this election will
block the nomination i think it's
possible it's just too early to know we
have to wait
uh we have to wait and see but we will
do that
because we have no choice but to wait
and see thanks to
you bender and christopher is here
both of whom have subscribed on twitch
very much appreciate that troy baker
says how do i explain the dangers of a
one-party state
to the non-politically engaged well uh
if we have a system built on checks and
balances
a one-party state let me put a different
way
if we believe checks and balances are
good by definition a one-party state
precludes and eliminates a bunch of
those checks and balances that are
possible
urban mask says stop saying mcconnell's
a hypocrite or has no morals it's true
but it overlooks his racism which was
the main blocker
for the garland appointment well that
may be but it is certainly not relevant
in terms of what's going to happen in
the next four months
i i don't know how else to say it i do
want to start letting you guys know
now that tuesday september 29th is the
first presidential debate between donald
trump and joe biden
we will be covering it live i am my goal
is for it to be the biggest stream we
have ever had now the biggest stream
we've ever had so far is about 50 000
live concurrent viewers so i don't have
any idea if it's possible
but i would love it if you join me
on the 29th of september i don't know
what time it is
sometime at night eastern 7 89 something
like that
uh we will be live live live live
powerfully live is i think the way
i would describe it um other super chats
fours says david does seeing the
virginia early voting lines give you
some optimism
on overall voter turnout yes and
early reports are that there are
uh there is a significant advantage for
democrats
over republicans in early voting early
voting that is really good
that's an excellent thing thanks to lazy
in wonderland for subscribing with
twitch prime
thanks to james mear for subscribing on
twitch
and thanks to gold 3n griffin
for subscribing with twitch prime the
next subscriber would be twitch
subscriber number one
thousand we are at 999
if you can imagine that that's a shout
out to uh
grandmaster benjamin feingold of course
as many of you know
um let's see what else we have going on
here
uh that's ghastly says trump said his
nomination will likely be a woman i did
not see that
oh i guess let's look this is something
interesting this is trump
yesterday now a lot was made out of this
was trump's genuine reaction to finding
out
rbg had just died although immediately a
bunch of people said
that this trump had been briefed and he
was pretending i don't know the truth
but let's look at it
by the way i have no idea why there's
music maybe it was playing in the
background at the rally
you're telling me now for the first time
she led an amazing life what else can
you say she was an amazing woman
whether you agreed or not she was an
amazing woman
who led an amazing life
um actually sad to hear that i have said
to you that thank you very much
okay anyway so um there were also
moments during yesterday's rally where
trump was talking about the supreme
court
and and people were screaming at him
that rbg
is dead it's completely surreal we're
it's like nothing i've seen it was
perverse and we're going to talk about
it
we're going to talk about monday's going
to be a crazy show i don't know how we
get caught up
we probably need a full week just to get
caught up
uh okay i don't know why donald trump
hasn't yet landed
this rally was scheduled for 6 pm
eastern time
and donald trump's plane has not even
landed yet
although people are standing now so
maybe
are we close now i guess something must
be about to happen it would seem
or maybe not some of these crowds you
know they stand for no reason
thanks for don kimmy don is new member
number 12 today
at joinpacman.com i really appreciate
that and love that folks are signing up
zach says got our wisconsin ballots
today hand delivering
monday beautiful beautiful chris says
trump is a germaphobe he said now that
the virus is here
he doesn't have to shake the hands of
his voter base all right i mean
you could be a germaphobe and be a good
president and a good person trump
happens to be neither but
that doesn't seem like a huge deal rob
says sorry about the 10
thanks for the great content thanks rob
i appreciate it appreciate the support
uh let's see mab says the death of rbg
is just another
nail in the coffin of democracy it
certainly feels like it could be
certainly feels like it could be we are
now back
in the quadruple digits for twitch subs
thanks to willie d trowda alpha omega
karsus monsef md
desparagus and
i guess that's it okay um all right very
good
zaximo the outlaw says as an american
living in norway
if trump gets another four years i'm
complimenting i'm contemplating
renting out a room in my house to help a
fellow american escape you know
doing my civil duty there you go
examine everything says the world's
watching in horror
remembering hitler okay
jorge says what tools can the dems use
to slow down the republican supreme
court nomination getting pushed through
if any uh they need to make they need to
find the sensible republicans there's
probably
a handful of them or something like that
um and they need to
get them to understand all of the
potentially bad things that will happen
if trump pushes this through and biden
wins
and uh you know
whether they care about that i don't i
don't know
i don't know okay i'm being told that
the rally actually was rescheduled
to 6 30. 6 30 tomorrow
no i'm kidding to 6 30 today let's see
if that's the case
yes it appears to have been rescheduled
to 6 30. that's very true
uh okay let's see if do you guys
want me to try to connect very briefly
with stephen kenneth destiny benell to
try to finish our conversation
that we had um in the in the little bit
of time that we have
i'll try to do it and then we'll keep an
eye on this
um because we got cut off last time
let me see here i have to make sure i
can get this all going the right way
going to try to get discord going um
but i'm going to miss my membership
pitch if i do this i'm not going to be
able to do a hard
sell of for people signing up at
jointpakman.com no i think we'll be okay
uh we'll have time for pitches let's see
if i can get
steven going here we go let's just take
my discord is updating now
um yeah i don't know how long we're
gonna have oh my god discord is just
taking forever
dear god downloading update one of 7252
that could take a while right
oh my goodness
all right i think now we're going to be
good i think what i'm going to try to do
is just
re-establish the sort of um
[Music]
oh no i think we're screwed guys now
there's a whole other slate of updates
happening now
oh my god yeah it's just not oh god
there's now another one
this is like that scene in office space
where progress indicators keep getting
to 100
and then they just start over oh my god
whoa what is going on here
let's see oh he's he's actually talking
to shirkah
right now i don't know what that means
zacherka
so i guess he can't talk to me right now
hmm
oh that oh he's not oh okay oh he's done
okay check in real quick
let's see if he we can raise him we're
trying to raise destiny
okay here we go stephen kenneth let's
see if we can do it
let me get my microphone and then for
speakers
let me see stephen hey what's up bud how
are you how are you doing my friend
pretty good how you doing are we uh like
have you you haven't cut me out because
of our conversation the other day right
no why would you think that there were a
lot of people saying that
there was a bridge being on the destiny
listen here yes so here's the joke okay
i
disagree with a lot of people
politically over things usually what
happens is when i have a political
disagreement with somebody
usually they and their fan base [ __ ]
hates me oh i can be friends with people
with
way different political leadership oh
okay interesting yeah i'm never gonna
like i disagree with you and i hate you
unless you like tell me that you want to
like kill all the jews or some crazy
[ __ ] like that right and i would never
don't thank you yeah yeah i don't think
that's gonna happen so yeah
so listen we obviously don't have time
for like the full discussion but what i
thought would be interesting to do would
be
okay just to establish some of the
reasons why i think the conversation was
misframed the other day
so would you allow me to do that yeah
and then like nobody didn't help it yeah
go ahead
sorry what did you say i was gonna say
the lag probably didn't help at all the
lag didn't help the
the conversation was misframed because
of the lag yes but more importantly
so here's the thing let me i'll give you
my thoughts on two things and then we'll
see where you're at so
you you kept wanting to talk about first
principles and i resisted that and then
afterwards there was this sort of
discussion that happened
discussion people emailed me and they
had different views about
about first principles versus the
specifics
my point is not that first principles
don't matter the point i was trying to
make was
unless we first establish what we're
talking about we might be talking about
principles that apply to
different situations and what i mean by
that is if we focus on
as an example the idea of can people
defend themselves
i don't actually believe that the
primary discussion to be had
about the kenosha thing is about that in
other words for me the context more is
what does it say about a society if
if things like that are encouraged if
things like that become more common etc
for me the legal aspect of self-defense
i've already conceded i think that on
one of the two counts
if this kid has good attorneys there's a
there's a good chance that
that at least on one of the two counts
it could go down to self-defense but so
my argument was not that first
principles don't matter it's that if
if we just jump into first principles we
might be talking about principles that
apply to
to other situations not the ones that
we're actually trying to discuss and for
me the the the principle of
can people defend things seemed like
just going in the wrong way
oh sure i mean i frame it as like a
moral like a self-defense conversation
the only reason why i like to start
first principles is just because i like
to have like a foundational idea of
where you're coming from
um because sometimes i feel like a lot
of arguments get lost where people start
arguing like a specific scenario
right the reality is is that they have a
fundamental disagreement that is like
they have to resolve that before they
can move further the best example i can
think of this is 99 of the time people
talk about abortion
there is a fundamental disagreement on
when a human life becomes a human life
okay having a conversation past that
point is a waste of time like
if you don't believe it's a life well of
course you can have an abortion of
course it's a matter of inconvenience to
the mother you can avoid it but if you
do believe it's a life well killing a
human to save someone for an
inconvenience is that's a really hard
sell but
most people that argue abortion don't
even talk about whether or not the fetus
is living they go on
and talk about like the choice of the
mother or what's right for the family
whatever they get like way past that
that's the only reason why i like to
like just get that foundation it could
be that we
have our discussion on self-defense and
we both agree
or disagree or at least we understand
each other and then maybe that principle
actually never comes up
maybe you argue totally differently like
well what is the practical um
if somebody goes and defends a small
business is that ever good even if they
are right to justify
uh self-defense does that actually help
us like and then it could be at that
point
maybe the self-defense principle doesn't
even come up it's just good to know that
in the back of my head so that i feel
like we're worth fair fair it just seems
like sometimes
the for the people who just want to talk
about first principles
are are focused on getting getting the
other person they're talking to
to agree to completely uncontroversial
vague overarching principles that very
few people would disagree with and it
doesn't even actually do anything to
move the conversation forward
sure but then i guess like what i would
figure is like the onus then would be on
me
um let's say that like um let's say that
somebody wants to have a conversation
and
and their their position is that all
brown immigrants are foreign invaders
right okay and then you what do we have
and then and then they start the
conversation do you think we have a
right to self-defense
i mean i would say well yeah of course
we do but then when we advance the
conversation i'm gonna say i don't
consider people immigrating to your land
to be aggressors that need to be
defended against even if we obtain those
first principles like i'm going to
disagree with your application of them
but then at least we can yeah start from
there i guess yeah
so then the the other thing and again
we're just for people who are wondering
i'm stuck
talking to stephen kenneth destiny
benell ii and we're just kind of res
we're reframing
we are pre-framing a conversation that
will subsequently happen
um the other thing that i thought was
getting us in the wrong direction was
for example
when i mentioned among other things that
kyle rittenhouse is 17 years old you
said well if he was 18 then would you be
okay with it and i said no and then you
said that his age is irrelevant i think
it's important
to talk about that we have to discuss
the situation that took place
and we could identify lots of factors
like for example
we we could if let me back up for a
second
just because one factor if different
wouldn't dramatically change my
perspective on the situation
doesn't mean the factor is irrelevant
it's sort of like saying
you know i i was uh i'm against um
you know i i'm against theft by
people under 20 or whatever and then you
say well what about someone who's 21
well no i'm also against that but
there's something particularly
pernicious about young people who are
getting involved in theft or whatever
i don't think that that it's
particularly relevant to say
that if i would also have a problem with
it if kyle rittenhouse was 18
then him being 17 is irrelevant it's
still part of the facts and part of the
story
yeah that's true um okay i'm gonna throw
out i'm gonna throw a debate lingo at
you okay
have you ever heard of the term gish
gallop have i heard of it of course
i've been interviewed by jessie lee
peterson oh okay there you go right
so the reason so i agree with you um so
for instance um let's say that like uh
the reason why i decided to move here
the reason why i decided to move here is
because i'm closer to friends i'm closer
to stores i'm closer to
uh city life blah blah and somebody
would ask me oh so if your friends
weren't there you wouldn't have moved
there
then i'd be like well no there's a whole
bunch of other reasons i'd move here too
right i think that
it's okay to build a case like that
that's totally fine good um
the only thing i worry about though is
that um
when we talk about so when i talk about
like a gish gallop what i'm saying is
sometimes what people will do is they'll
build an
argument on four or five or six very
weak legs that individually none are
justified
but taken collectively appear to build a
very powerful argument
so i i go back to racist examples i'm so
used to arguing against race realist so
like a race realist might say
um black crime is the same all over the
world we know that black people have
warrior genes we know that black people
biologically have less iq than us and
then we know that black people are more
predisposed to violence so how can you
oppose me saying that we
right when somebody says that it's like
well hold on we have to go back and
argue over
every single one of these premises
because i disagree with every point so
if somebody tells me like oh well so
kyle rittenhouse was underage
he acquired the weapon illegally he was
in a place where he wasn't supposed to
be like okay well let's go back if he
was 18 would that change anything
well no i think it's something okay well
what if he'd acquired the weapon legally
would that change anything well maybe
not and
okay well what if he um you know did
have standing to be there let's say that
he owned that guy's station
right so that's why i like to just walk
through and examine each thing it's okay
to say well on its own this one thing
doesn't build my argument but i still
think
it's a supporting case it's a supporting
piece but that's why i just like to go
through and look at it i have like a
very like big building block approach to
like making arguments basically
so that that's fair and then the third
thing would be i think that for us to
more productively talk about it we
probably have to agree on the facts like
for example you know you
you threw out this thing of well you
know this was this was the
this was the old what if this kid is the
only kid who can go and defend the
business and it's like it's
it's ridiculous to think that a 17 year
old from a different state
using a gun that's not even his is the
last resort for defending a business
the the the violent incidents didn't
even take place
at the business that he was supposedly
defending et cetera so i do think that
we we should establish the facts in
order to more productively talk about it
and you know honestly
i think that in the end it sounds like
we both agree
that this is not a country that would be
better off
if it was based on the regular defense
of businesses by 17 year olds with guns
and we probably would agree that there's
a chance that is not an unreasonable
chance that this kid is not going to be
found guilty at least on one of the
counts like i don't know that we
disagree on that much on it i don't know
yeah probably not i just want to be very
careful because
this conversation is just happening in a
certain political slant
but i wouldn't want to i wouldn't want
to be held to a principle about this
argument
that if i were to try to apply it to
another one now all of a sudden i'm
morally bankrupt so for instance
i absolutely do think that if black
communities were being marched on by
white racists who were trying to kill
them for for no reason
um and the cops weren't doing anything i
would absolutely defend black
communities not only defending their
lives but defending their livelihoods
if we had like a like a like a black
wall street incident or like a tulsa
race riots where black people
were being marched upon by murderous
white lynch mobs i think that they
should absolutely be able to defend not
only their lives but their properties
um with lethal force as well so i
wouldn't want to commit myself to
anything in one argument that i'd throw
away in the other if a different type of
um a different class of person i guess
like a minority or
uh like women versus medicine was
involved basically yeah
yeah well i don't think you have to
pre-commit to anything to say
that if we think about uh how is this
country
going to improve it's not by 17 year
olds with guns from the next state over
defending businesses like i think who
we there's no way we could we would say
that that's that's the the next
phase for the country that's how the
country will improve and evolve
sure that is true but
um it we i guess that we get into the
weeds because there's
like i don't think that all people are
morally compelled
to act in ways that 100 will
um commit them to doing things for the
benefit of all of society i don't
necessarily think that's true um as a
quick so as a quick example of this this
is very very loaded
but we might run into problems in the
future where we can't replace our
children
because women are getting more and more
reproductive and economic freedoms
and they realize hold on having kids
sucks like
i'd rather why would i give away 10 of
the best years of my career building
part of my life to have a [ __ ] kid
like a lot of women are making that
decision and you see that reflected in
birth
right it's all across the western world
i would never say like okay
listen up women okay the feminism game
was fun but we got to start pumping
babies out we're literally like losing
populations in our country we can't
support our old people and our countries
are fading away like time to stop
playing you know
uh working woman and go back to being a
housewife right i don't think you can
commit somebody
to a position that might benefit all of
society but individually overrides their
autonomy
oh my god i have no idea what you're
talking about with that
but i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
go back and listen i don't know how
that's even remotely applicable to what
we're talking about
um but sure what i'm saying is that i
don't know if people going out and
defending their property with violence i
don't know if that builds an overall
better society i don't know if that
makes
america a better place but i wouldn't
compel a man to watch his business burn
because it might not benefit the overall
narrative of the country right and i
would say that
nobody that there it is completely
unrealistic
that a business burning or not burning
depends on a 17 year old from a
different state with an illegal gun
maybe not just a 17 year old but some
level of militia defense is entirely
plausible for sure
historically there's precedent and then
even potentially within these own riots
it might there might be precedent
oh my goodness okay well i mean i guess
that's that's a different issue
but um okay all right listen think hey
are you back in the u.s or are you still
in europe
back in the u.s oh you are okay area of
la yeah and
how was it and it looked you were in
copenhagen which i i just love that's
one of my favorite places
yeah it's a super super super cute place
holy [ __ ] yeah
was this i'm i caught wind was there
controversy that
you were you were like out streaming at
restaurants and like random bystanders
were in the stream and there was
controversy over it
i mean every now and then people get
upset that they're being filmed or
whatever i don't know i think it's kind
of dumb i usually try to be like pretty
respectful of people if i'm streaming
like i try to make sure my camera's not
aimed at anybody but this were like
people in the background like 10 tables
away were like staring at us like the
whole time i don't think anybody knew
they were there or heard anything
but i i guess they just got a little bit
irked whatever and it's just kind of
dumb but and is this
is this like is this molina's thing like
she's doing these kind of irl streams
yeah she like travels around your air
open streams and whatnot yeah got it got
it got i got it
uh okay all right very good well listen
i know i know you have a busy schedule
ahead of you and we've got this trump
rally starting up
so let's um i think that now we've sort
of we've pre-negotiated the debate and
the debate may no longer even be
necessary thanks to the pre-negotiation
sure maybe i guess
all right man i'll talk to you soon okay
okay good luck dave all right don't cut
me out
don't cut me out okay okay [ __ ] you all
right all right see you later
there it is stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell
ii okay very good we are now
moments from the start of this rally
donald trump now
almost certainly certainly certainly
close to landing
um let me do let me do uh real quick
twitch thank yous
claire g has subscribed bolo
physics lad burnt crystal
soynin lizardo level up gamer
karsus okay no karsus i already think
very good
so we're caught up there um
what else do we have super chats
actually wait before i do that
one other new member martha reid
is new member number 13
today at joinpakman.com
okay other super chats coming in
um what do we have here
joey ruggiero says the pack is
back i hope you're well rested and ready
for more
red hot dumpster fires i am ready
skepel says welcome back from vacation i
can finally shower again yeah a lot of
people were on
um they were they were protesting by not
showering it was weird
steven parmee says if there is a
democratic majority in the house and
senate what is the relevance of the
supreme court can the court's influence
be avoided no
there are all sorts of decisions that
have nothing to do with the house and
senate
that go to the supreme court um and it
let's not for a moment
let's not for a moment fall into that
kind of thinking
okay well i just missed a bunch let me
scroll back
up desiree dewitt says
it's now more important than ever to get
the tangerine terror out
let's harness rbg's strength and vote
this lawless administration out i agree
i agree nay's garden with a 50
super chat the largest super chat today
wow
spoiling shows for your audience how is
trump unhinged if the event has yet to
start
i think trump was stately as he stepped
out of the event and was informed all
right very good
vegetable television says any tips on
improving kick drum technique
yeah so there's this book um let me see
here's the book i recommend for
kick drum technique ah this is a
beautiful book
this is the book right here okay this is
for developing good kick drum technique
i recommend also
you uh you even if you don't typically
play with a double pedal
set up a double pedal when you use this
book bass drum control by colin bailey
it has all sorts of exercises as you can
see they're
left right exercises now you can use
high hat and kick if you want
i used to practice these more with a
with a double pedal
or you can even alternate you can play
the left foot alternating between high
hat and your your
double double pedal this is just amazing
stuff
this is really really good stuff um and
in addition to doing exercises like
these
um learn to play heal up and heal down
and you know obviously in in real
playing situations
you would um you you would you would
just intuitively know
typically from the tempo and the amount
of volume you're looking for
you would know whether you want to play
heel up or heel down
but being able to play slow
and fast soft and loud heel up
and heel down um i think is really
useful so that's the book i would
recommend
sam dean says g'day mate victorian fine
for not wearing a mask is 200
maximum fine for breaking curfew is 19
000. we're not messing around you rock
mate fork bomb
says happy birthday david thank you it
is months away but i appreciate that
unknown prodigy cannot believe that
these idiots are maskless
yeah they it's it's insane it's insane
susan lloyd says fantastic show chris
chuck says hey david congratulations on
1 million subscribers i have a question
how do i get my apathetic friends to
vote for biden without coming off as
rude
i don't know i don't know i'd have to
hear more about you know
their point of view uh maybe try calling
into the show on wednesday
um okay if you're just joining us this
rally was scheduled for 36 minutes ago
it was rescheduled for six minutes ago
and as you can see
it has not yet started um but we are
expecting
touchdown by donald trump just about
any moment just about any moment here
if you're watching on twitch please make
sure to follow me on twitch we are
so close so close to 50 000 followers on
twitch which would be a great
accomplishment meanwhile on youtube
we are close to 1.1 million
subscribers so please subscribe on
youtube it's free
it costs nothing nothing nothing nothing
and we are pushing towards 1.1
million million subscribers
mike pyro says there isn't a thousand
people in camera view
about a hundred people per bleacher
okay sam
burstin says thoughts on a new civil war
can the military crush it well i think
part of the idea of a civil war is the
military could be involved
um but i i'm hoping that we're gonna be
short of uh short of a civil war
i'm i'm hoping to avoid one donna
williams says please reiterate by
why voting third party is a vote for
trump thank you well listen
if if voting for third party is not a
vote for trump
if you don't if you like trump right if
you like trump
and you want trump to win and you vote
third party uh then you're hurting trump
if you don't want trump to win and you
vote third party
you're helping trump essentially um
particularly in those close
close states that could be the
difference makers a lot of people are
pointing so it seems as though the plane
maybe is getting close we can we can
sort of hope
when the crowd all pointing
let's see what's going on from the
standpoint of audio
[Music]
okay so elton john currently playing all
right i can't imagine
elton john is okay with that paul ames
says how do you think this affects the
supreme court legal fight for this
election we won't know until we know
whether trump pushes someone in
so there's actually choppers in the back
are we expecting
trump via chopper here did he actually
land elsewhere
with the plane let me take a look
fayetteville president arrives
no it looks like it's the plane that's
landing yeah
not the uh not the chopper
looks like the choppers are just there
just in case i guess
okay um clinky winky
says trump wants to replace rbg as quick
as possible doesn't he trust his base to
elect him again so he could take his
time
also congrats for one million um
stephen does stuff says you should
debate tim poole again
[Laughter]
d lusk says who do you think trump will
blame for his tardiness he won't even
mention it
won't even mention it william denny says
viewer from canada here
wish i could vote but love all your
coverage and viewpoints keep up the
great work thank you
nay's garden says thoughts on the
people's party i i don't know enough
about it
to um intelligently intelligently opine
i'm guessing that the plane must be here
because people seem to before people
were looking sort of to screen left
and now a lot of people are looking kind
of to screen
right so i wonder if the plane is there
and just
circling to land or what's going on
people very very excited though very
very excited
um okay thanks to alexander the grape
who subscribed with twitch and says hey
david
what do you think of the dems packing
the supreme court if the republicans
nominate a conservative justice before
the election if they win
well for me it's not if they nominate i
think trump will nominate for me it's
if they get him get a a a judge
confirmed
and i would probably be in favor of
packing the court
in that case yeah but i'm going to talk
more about that on monday
samuel lopez says davidsito felicidades
if you're not from argentina yes by the
way did you guys see my spanish language
interview
i have an hour-long spanish language
interview
on my youtube channel subtitled
beautifully
by me in english so
if you speak spanish or if you speak
english
and you can read i guess you would be
able to
understand it and i encourage you to
check that out i think that's really
good
master krepta says david who would you
say is the worst possible choice trump
could make to replace
rbg maybe ted cruz
ted cruz would be pretty bad yeah
mike b pyro says closed captioning has a
hot mic
yeah there were things coming up
what does 10 mean why are people holding
up two hands does anybody know what that
means
or nine i have no idea what that means
anybody janine pirro might be even worse
than ted cruz
oh 45 4 and 5 10 more years yeah
who knows hey look here's someone with a
mask
it's like what are you even doing there
horrible
horrible horrible horrible archimedes
has subscribed on twitch with the
message for the many
not the all very much like that
uh as the sun is setting in fayetteville
north carolina we await donald trump's
arrival
um christopher pineda says i don't know
but i have this strange feeling when
trump is alone
he takes a moment to break down and cry
knowing his base is as disgusting as he
is
i would love to think in private trump
is crying about
the people that support him that would
be interesting i just don't know that
it's the case
solange gregory says if the dems let
them get away with replacing ginsberg do
we agree we riot
it's not about riot uh but we're going
to talk about
what can the left do what is within our
control
and what is beyond our control that's
the way we will be
talking about it but no i don't agree
that we riot
eric says surprised more celebrities
aren't endorsing biden
i think i think many are i don't know
so everybody now looking over to the
right it must be that the plane has
circled around right and is about to
land let's at least hope so
if you're just joining us this event was
scheduled to start originally 45 minutes
ago then rescheduled to 15 minutes ago
and it appears as though uh any moment
now
donald trump's plane is going to land
i will shortly be going into a hard sell
membership pitch which i think is going
to be a pretty good one
estherian says this
this is my theory trump is trying to
worsen the outbreak
to make phase three vaccine trials go
quicker
which means vaccine results by election
no i don't believe that because i don't
think donald trump understands the
connection between those things
uh okay people waving and cheering now i
guess it's because they're tossing
t-shirts out to the crowd to placate the
crowd
isaac cloud says can you referee a fight
between ben shapiro and destiny the
fight would be really short
sure sure i would love to do that
9000 ck says hello david if trump wins
the gop
will the gop remove him no no no no if
trump wins
he wins and he's who's going to be
president caden
tonita says what are your thoughts on
modern monetary theory
is it all hype and no substance seems
compelling to me yeah i've talked about
it many times i've interviewed stephanie
kelton about it
multiple times and i encourage you to
check out
my youtube channel for those videos i
think you will like those videos very
very much
renholder says i love the usa chants at
these rallies as if he's running against
a foreign opponent
well it's not only that trump is acting
like somebody else has been president
the last four years he's acting like we
need to
um we need to elect him in order to take
control back uh and it's like dude
you've been president this entire time
people seem to have turned almost
completely all the way around now
so i i'm hoping that the plane now
is just off to our right off the screen
and about to land a lot of people
pointing they seem to have identified a
plane in the air
someone here with a long lens as you can
see
uh taking some photographs
and now people waving uh oh now i'm
getting texts
let me turn my phone down that's very
rude of me
yeah people it's like what are people
leaving what are you waving to i don't
even understand it's
sort of unusual
taxiing now oh okay he must have he must
have landed already okay
let's see if any one of these has a
different view
uh is the pla the plane must be down
right
i think we're gonna see now
maybe oh no it has not landed yet
apparently
there is the plane
people seeming to find the landing
lights there alright very good so the
plane
is coming in very soon yeah i i see
people wondering like ima
what is going on in your life where you
show up and get crammed
into a small space and wait around for
hours
to see trump land to see trump speak
rather
it is very bizarre behavior i i agree
david ball
is new member number 14 today
at joinpakman.com appreciate it david
thank you very very much for your
support
we are just minutes minutes from the
landing of donald trump in
fayetteville north carolina for another
corona speech
let's see other super chats coming in
um where was that
man trump rally on right-wing youtube
channel
i missed a bunch of them oh okay
leo lee leo says hey david my wife loves
your show so i just had to sub
thanks for being so smart and amazing
thank you i appreciate that say hi to
your wife for me
danny's lay says i was watching a trump
rally on a right-wing youtube channel i
think it was called right side the
commentary was hilarious
that's this that's what we've got right
here yes
yes and you guys it's unbelievably cold
here
but it's so worth it at this time i feel
like we're both smiling from like
phil collins now what what is this music
i can't imagine trump uh
any of this music is approved by any of
the artists
um vivek kumar says vivek from india is
biden the best candidate for
president it is my opinion he lacks the
conviction for the role
anyone is better than trump the best
candidate guys
we've got 46 days to until an election
okay
is he the best candidate you know if we
could pick anybody certainly we no but
this is this is who is it who it is
let's not lose sight of that
do you think he's constantly late to
maximize crowd volatility
sort of like the rick and morty slow
ramp technique i don't know
i think he's just late because he
doesn't care uh
okay donald trump finally arriving
49 minutes after the originally
scheduled start time for this rally
finally arriving in the small plane
today
in the 757 in fayetteville north
carolina
and it looks like we are probably you
know no more than a couple of hours from
the start of this thing
um and people
very very excited
um yeah unclear
uh reportedly very cold on the ground we
don't know
how long donald trump is expected to
speak
uh but we do know that there will be
likely
some commentary about um
and there it is about ruth bader
ginsburg and we will
very very soon see exactly what the
extent of that is
uh you know every time we talk about
trump did this crazy thing
trump did that crazy thing i then of
course am reminded
there are 60 million people who are
gonna vote for this garbage
and as i've said before win or lose
we are going to have to deal with 60
million trumpists in our country
regardless and that is horrifying that
is horrifying and that is a completely
and totally toxic
um and and we'll have time to discuss
that but i do have a clip
um about that out on my youtube channel
already so donald trump has landed
and uh the plane is taxing around
and we will soon hear from donald trump
other super chats coming in great
opportunity for you to get a super chat
into me
tristan mccoppen says wouldn't be
shocked if trump appointed
the kenosha kid to the supreme court
yeah that may be too much even for trump
michael says my last super chat was miss
worded i meant obama was blocked from
filling a supreme court position has
this happened to others
i don't believe it has happened in the
modern era that another president was
like
timed out by the other party i don't
believe so
um but there have certainly been
candidates who withdrew
donald trump george w bush had that
woman whose name i forget
there's of course you know getting
borked as many of you know
um yeah but i don't know that it's
happened in that exact way
the price of drama says hey david i
wanted to tell you a thousand plus
idiots
were gathering at a dumb rally worsening
covet in the u.s
but i didn't want to create a panic for
you thank you i appreciate that i'm glad
that you didn't panic me
cabin says do you think the new scotus
vacancy will do anything to help
convince remaining never biden holdouts
on the left before november 3rd
yeah i do i mentioned this earlier i
actually do think that
whatever the outcome is of donald trump
trying to fill that seat
on the supreme court i believe that the
possibility of trump now doing this
will activate some of the never biden
people
some people who weren't planning on
voting at all um
but who if they did vote would vote for
joe bide i think we are absolutely going
to see them activated no question about
it
and i think it's going to increase
turnout jeremiah
maudlin is new member number 15
today at joinpakman.com i very very much
appreciate that we are just moments
moments from the uh oh hold on a second
you know what
we've got a few people that i need to
ban in the chat i'm sorry
i i apologize but there's some real
clowns
uh okay
yeah we just took care of a couple
people we dropped the band hammer
remember bands are free guys so we're
not going to run out
if anybody would like to request a ban
by all means let me know
okay olivia page says david pakman has
a score of 4.86
out of 5 on wikifeet men congrats on the
above average feet david oh this i have
to see
wikifeet david pakman
oh my god
these pictures are wild
yeah there's pictures of my feet that is
bizarre
okay incredible all right a very
important question
jeremiah maudlin asks how do we gift
memberships from the membership website
it's tough
really the only we don't have a good
system right now
really the only way to gift a membership
right now is you
sign up for the person you're gifting it
to and then you put in your payment info
and then you let them know the username
and password which they can change
that's really that's really the only um
that's really the only way at this point
in time
uh speaking of memberships listen i'm
not going to spend a lot of time on this
but i do want to mention it our program
is mostly funded by people who get
memberships on our website as you know
over the years we've had these issues
where
you know youtube revenue is going well
and then boom it's cut
adpocalypse hits and we have no control
no control over it or we have
advertisers and then
covet hits and then advertisers panic
and they all say we've got to cancel
cancel cancel and we lose the ad revenue
okay
we have very little control over that
website memberships we have total
control over
and it's our number one funding source
so as i like to say
if you think that what i'm doing is a
disaster don't support it i don't want
your support
if you hate me personally don't get a
membership by just get the hell out of
here okay
but if you do value uh the live streams
and the clips and the podcasts and the
content and all of this different stuff
and you're not down to your last dollar
i don't want anybody's last dollar
grab a membership at jointpakman.com
it's very quick
it's easy you get an extra show every
day
made just for you and if you apply that
coupon code above my head
2020 now you will save 66
so we're talking about you know 1.83 a
month
if you pay for the year 2 bucks a month
if you want to pay monthly so again if
you can't
do that because of financial reasons do
not sign up
okay we're not looking for anybody's
last couple bucks
but uh we do depend on memberships for
uh as our primary
source of support so come on in this is
what you call freedom
exactly as people are saying the show is
free no matter what
but if you want to sign up if you can
sign up you are welcome to do it and i
will thank you profusely
like for example serena
villegas serena villegas is new member
number
16. david bohannon
is new member number 17 beautiful
okay beautiful we love it we absolutely
love it
okay um we are
continuing to wait for donald trump now
an hour late
now an hour late um
dodging the rain says
dodge a ring of fires fahren cousins a
friend of mine yes
will later provide info on where to
report poll watchers and other people
trying to interfere with your voting
excellent
excellent omar says you missed my last
super chat okay let's find it
omar would you come on the podcast
pka destiny's a frequent guess i have no
idea
you know you gotta if people want me on
podcasts they have to contact me through
my website contact form
and then we go through a screening
process and you know different things
happen so
nay's garden says watching this rally is
like watching a giant russian roulette
game in slow motion two weeks will be
too long to wait
to see the damage done and how many
others will these people infect who did
not
attend great question great question
solange gregory says fellow argentinian
after what they did to merrick garland
nothing
should be off the table right
very well said um
patty says it must cost a fortune to fly
that huge plane out for an hour of lies
are we paying for that yes
yes in theory since this is a campaign
event and it's considered a campaign
event on donald trump's website
uh on the uh donald trump schedule in
theory the campaign is supposed to
reimburse
the taxpayer i don't think it's
happening
i don't think it's happening uh okay
members are very powerfully
stacking up calvin findlay is new member
number 18
lee partington is new member number 19
and payne hoover is new member number
20 at joinpakman.com very much
appreciate that thank you so much
if we can get to 25 we're gonna go for
50.
we're gonna go we're gonna go for it
see here john berger asks whether i
think supreme court justices should have
a term limit yeah
i do and i've i've said that before
jeremiah maudlin says boo that's
horrible i just wanted to provide
for many anonymous whoevers well
jeremiah if you want to do some
anonymous gifting
or rather some gifting twitch actually
has an entire system now correct me if
i'm wrong
on twitch how do you request a gift
subscription like how does someone who
gifts subscriptions
know who wants them i actually don't
understand how
is there a list or something like that
i've never really understood how that
works
it's random oh oh oh it's an algorithm
and how does someone do the gifting
we don't know okay
you beg and plead
you can give it to a certain person okay
well listen in any case
there's a lot of gifting mechanisms and
elements of gifts
available over on twitch that's a
beautiful place to do it
philip black says do you think trump is
mad they didn't use the 747
no try listen trump's been doing a lot
of these smaller airports
um where they they don't bring the uh
the 747
okay forza says you missed mine too
david
i don't think i did i think i got that
one
no i talked about virginia early voting
oh wait this one david i also feel like
the trump bases association
with being anti-massacres will lose the
election for trump
americans find them crazier than antifa
that's possible that's certainly
possible yeah
that that could be it's just very hard
to predict how any
any uh here's what's difficult
the it's not ever clear what will
activate someone and get them to go from
being
you know a registered voter to a likely
voter or a likely voter to someone who
actually work
does vote but when you have 60 million
lunatics that voted for trump
it's even harder to know what might turn
them on or off
from their candidate or from voting or
or from whatever very very tough
some other new members to thank jerry
maines is new member number 21.
aaron winter is number 22.
sam nazaridian is number 23.
tony treadway is number 24 and shane
miller
is number 25. so you know what guys
let's do it let's uh let's go for 50.
uh number 26 is daniel pasmino
number 27 is tadzia h
28 is trent bolt and 29 is erica cortez
garcia
thank you so much really appreciate it
we should probably be
within a couple hours of trump starting
at this rate
jeremiah maudlin says is it though
twitch
and are there many mechanisms yes yes
gifting subscriptions on twitch is very
easy
very very easy i don't know how to do it
but i'm told it's extremely is easy
miles says congratulations on one
million
subscribers uh i've been subscribed to
your youtube since 2016.
have you seen aoc's video on rbg's
passing i recommend watching i haven't
seen it yet but other people in the chat
have recommended it
and i look forward to checking it out
for sure
there is donald trump working his way
down the stairs let's see what's going
on
oh my god they're doing that song again
um
okay can i interview
harrison to help the south carolina race
that's actually a very good idea
i should try to interview jamie harrison
let's see if we can do it
um i'm actually i'll just make a
reminder on my calendar
to let producer pat know to try to get
that going
jamie harrison that would be really good
and we might actually be able to get him
we really might
okay we are going to be hearing from
donald trump shortly
this rally scheduled to start
63 minutes ago today
uh minutes ago uh this minute and
um it didn't it didn't but donald trump
finally finally making it here
i love all of these new people that are
signing up
jacob rowe is number 30.
chase powelson is number 31 matthew
parker number 32
nicole vath is number 33.
donald trump wearing the long overcoat
as we are told it is
very very chilly in fayetteville today
we don't know if this will be an
adderall field speech
or a benzo uh
what would be the opposite of fueled a
benzo
uh declined speech i don't know
um oh my goodness somebody just gifted
50 subscriptions
on twitch oh my god we've never had a 50
subscriber
50 subscribers gifted at once over on
twitch that is
we are being doused in subscribers
for lack of a better term that is
incredible
it seems that that's poggers yeah i
don't know if that's good or bad but it
seems good
all right we are going to hear from
donald trump momentarily
fit completed defiance thank you for
gifting 50 subscriptions
on twitch an unbelievable day an
unbelievable day gigapog
i think is the way the kids would say it
let's see if they've still got the music
going
we're going to need a little more volume
i think
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
can you imagine being this excited to
hear donald trump speak
by the way not that i care i think
trump's an idiot because of what he says
but his face is two colors it's like his
ear has no makeup on it it's bizarre
come on let him come over what is a big
crowd
is always big we want to win we got his
voice sounds messed up
our country from the radical left
erratica left crazies
thank you very much and hello north
carolina hello
north carolina he sounds sick right it's
sick or drunk but he doesn't drink it
seems downers downer trump or sick trump
well with thousands of loyal
hard-working americans
patriots
[Applause]
45 days from now and you're watching
those polls they go up up
up up thanks paris for the best five
days from now we're going to win north
carolina we're going to win
four more years in the white house
right
[Applause]
as we meet tonight our nation mourns the
loss of illegal giants supreme court
justice here we go
peter ginsburg going right to it her
landmark ruling's fierce devotion to
justice and her
courageous battle against cancer inspire
all americans
you may agree you may not disagree with
her but
you may agree or you may not disagree
beautiful a tremendous number of people
i say all americans
the audio's toxic let's see if we can
get it here
courageous battle against cancer inspire
all americans
you may agree you may not disagree with
her but
she was an inspiration to a tremendous
number of people
i say all americans
a friend of ours a friend of mine
justice scalia
he can barely talk tonight it's bizarre
powerful reminder that we can
disagree on fundamental issues while
treating each other with decency
dignity and respect our thoughts
and prayers are with your family thank
you very much
thank you thank you this is bizarre guys
so article two of our constitution says
the president shall
nominate justices of the supreme court
there it is there it is
i think this backfires and it activates
a lot of democratic voters oh
i don't think so what do you think tom
tom tillis i don't think it can be any
more clear
trey gowdy this could only happen in
north carolina
[Applause]
imagine trey gowdy on this i i think i
don't want to be
hyperbolic but if trey gowdy was on the
court i think i would move to one of the
other countries i could move to
a lot of fakers well i hope they hear so
the chance is a new one
fill that seat this is the chair
this can only happen to me phil that's
it
no it says the president is supposed to
fill the seat right
and that's what we're going to do we're
going to fill the scene
here we go i love that
we hear more chants there's a lot of
genius in those chants
half the time you said it better than
you can say it you can
read a speech but what's better than
those words fill that seat
you know what you do you come up you say
fill that seat you leave and you've said
everything you don't have to vote
he seems altered he seems altered right
now you can see open during an election
year
or prior to an inauguration 29 times
that's a lot
every single time the sitting president
made a nomination that included
did you ever hear of george washington
nomination
something is weird was jefferson
or how about the great abraham lincoln
when he wore the hatters
with a great hat i want to try one of
those hats i love that
now think of it 29 times
every single time nobody said oh let's
not fill the seat
we won the election now then we have
some senators that you know
forget it you know i recall that in 2016
that's not the way it went
i won't say it susan i won't say it
susan
but tom tillis is with us i can tell you
that right
he may soon be gone from the senate
fortunately tom tillis
great we have great republican senators
we have great people
and we have a great country that's
[Applause]
brilliant
so we win an election and those are the
consequences you know it's called fill
that seat and that's what we're doing
the supreme court
was a very central issue in both the
2016
presidential election and then the 2018
midterm elections where by the way i
didn't run you know we had a lot of
people
a lot of people said oh he really took a
little bit of a slack and not nearly as
bad as others in fact we gained seats in
the senate but they never talk about
that
right they don't talk about that we
gained two seats nobody talked about it
but we didn't run and i had a lot of
people that sir
will never vote in 2018. i said no no
vote everybody vote
they just did i think we were like nine
million
people decided they wanted to wait and
they've waited and you see what's going
on you see what's happening you see the
what is he talking about that we have
which by the way
we set a record in 2016. the bad news
with the democrats is
we are more enthusiastic now not even
close
than we were in 2016.
i mean we are getting crowds and this is
pandemic and we're rounding the turn
we're rounding the corner of the
pandemic
yeah i'm outside and we shouldn't say
this is some kind of a rally
from now on it's called a protest we are
protesting
this is like the dumbest the whole
peaceful protest thing is so stupid
you see a lot of these uh let's call
them
blue states we want to be we're going to
call it a
protest against stupidity he's in a
state that may well look pretty blue
after november 4th by the way
[Applause]
because you know a lot of the
people like in michigan and other places
we love michigan but the governor's got
them shut down
i hate to say it your governor's got you
shut down it doesn't look it here
that's not true north carolina is open
uh your governor has got you shut down i
don't know
you're not breaking the law by being
here otherwise if you are if you are
we'll have to do something about that
because
now there's a hell of a shutdown
i think your governor has to let this
state open up
it's open
and pennsylvania look what they're doing
in pennsylvania a great state where
that's actually something very special
is going to happen here in pennsylvania
that's a commonwealth
we always have to remember pennsylvania
commonwealth got two of them and you
better remember you get in trouble
isn't it pennsylvania virginia and
massachusetts
governor's got to just shut down nice
and tight and you know what on
november 4th it's going to be opened up
fall
[Applause]
because they're trying to hurt our
numbers but our economic numbers are so
good they're staggering they're the best
we've ever had
jobs retail stock market
everything and this is with a lot of
shutdowns by democrats that's all
they're doing
on november 4th they'll announce we've
decided to open up one of the teachers
groups said actually one of the unions
and one of the politicians in california
said
no we're not going to do it we need to
do it we should be open by
november 4th that was not a good thing
for them to
that person i think was fired i think
was fine
in both the 2016 and the 2018 elections
the american people chose
a president and a senate majority
united in their commitment to selecting
nominees who believe in applying the
constitution
as written right both the white house
and the senate majority
have a moral duty to fulfill the
promises they
made to the voters and that is exactly
what we're going to do
we said that if for any reason we have a
vacancy
on the united states supreme court we
will fill that vacancy we're not going
to say
and by the way we have plenty of time
there's a lot of time you know you're
talking about
you're talking about january 20th right
this this is what the downfall of
democracy looks like i hope people
understand
so we will uphold equal justice under
the law for citizens of every race color
religion and creed
i will be putting forth the nominee next
week
it will be a woman
it will be a woman unless wait
okay let's do a poll oh there they are
how many of these have you come to
speaking of women how many of the what
is this
number one like 90
they're great north carolina though
right
i see them all over the place they're
great i hope your husbands are okay with
it are they okay
they're okay you have good husbands but
we're gonna do a vote
okay so i said you know i love these
free polls
because pollsters and you know most of
the posters right surveying 400 people
at a trump rally is the way to really
figure out what america wants
we wouldn't be here right now but we're
actually getting very good we just had a
53 from rasmussen which is very good
considering we won uh four years ago
with a lot lower than 53
history has shown that when you're at 53
you can't lose an election
has anyone ever lost an election with a
53 the answer
is yes when the other side cheats
that could happen that could happen that
could happen you saw what happened in
pennsylvania
right some state supreme court justice
just ruled
that they can take as long as they want
to count the ballots that means
i'll be leading and winning pennsylvania
like we did last time
yeah yeah we'll be leading this is the
one poll he's referring to
easy we're going to win your state
easily
you know i just came off the plane with
by the way
our great chief of staff mark meadows
did anybody ever hear of mark
[Applause]
and deb what a great she's doing such a
good job but you know mark
just a few months ago i've been trying
to get him for three years to leave
and we have a great person running as
you know
really i mean really great does everyone
know madison yes you're going to vote
for madison
he's great he's a great guy but mark had
a beautiful head of black hair
and i just noticed that hair's turning
white very fast
but we're doing the job you know we're
very close to a great deal with
tick-tock
tick-tock but nobody cares about that
anymore all they care about is
fill that seat trump always was the only
one who cared about it
until about uh 24 hours ago that's all
they talked about is tick tock tick tock
well we have a deal worked out i think
with walmart is going to buy it along
with oracle
larry ellison uh it's going to be an
incredible combination
and i said you know do me a favor could
you put up
five billion dollars into a fund
for education so we can educate people
as to
real history of our country the real
history not the fake history
this is actually starting to be sort of
like these strongman dictator type
speeches
he determines what business deals are
done he determines what's taught what
what education what's patriotic
education they're going to move
probably to the great state of texas
sorry we've got you a lot of business
money
but they're going to move into the
united states which is what's important
they're going to move it to the united
states
unbelievable company they're going to
have 25
000 jobs if it all goes i gave them the
preliminary approval
but they're putting up 5 billion dollars
and my only problem is they did it so
fast i should have asked for more
you know what happened is when i
suggested they should put up
a lot of money everybody said senators
congressmen women everybody they said
you can't do that that's ever been done
that's the problem nothing's ever been
done
and we had other companies a lot of
people wanted it and i said you got to
put up five billion dollars either to
the treasury of the united states maybe
or
into some education fund or do something
and they were sort of agreeing with me
they thought it was okay
and then i went to the legal eagles here
and i said they're gonna put up five
million dollars give it to the united
states
so you can't do that there's no
provision i said how the hell can there
be no provision
we're making the deal possible why can't
they give us five
billion dollars let's be with them
that's a lot of money right
now watch the crazy democrats they'll go
they should have got more money right
it's never been done before they should
have no matter what you do they should
have gotten more
schumer what on earth is he talking
about
but i'll tell you and i said it last
night we had a great rally last night
you saw that right
toxic place that we're gonna win we're
gonna win minnesota hasn't been won
since 1972
and they're all saying well we did give
them back
the big iron ore range it was obama took
it away with the stroke of a pen
someone just yelled sick heil we gave it
back but i'll tell you what
uh we're going to have a victory on
november 3rd
the likes of which you've never seen
now we're counting on the federal court
system to make it so that we can
actually have an evening where we know
who wins
okay not that's code for using the
courts to stop counting absentee ballots
but in just three and a half years under
my administration we've secured
america's borders
rebuilt the awesome power of the u.s
military think of that
and i shouldn't say this and the fake
news keeps going oh
he's giving away classified information
no i'm not
we are building and we have built
weapons
the likes of which this world has never
seen before
and i said that a week ago this is the
guy that last week
even some on the left were saying he's
against the military industrial complex
special information these people are
crazy
no no i'm just telling you that
president putin and president xi of
china
russia china north korea
everybody uh they are so envious of what
we're doing
they can't even believe it if they know
they perhaps don't know
you know under obama they knew
immediately okay
under uh what does that even mean we
have we are building
weapons all made in the usa the likes
well china's not going to be jealous of
the weapons we're buying from china
that's for sure
has ever seen before and hope to god
we never have to use them let's see key
i don't
ever want to use him remember i was
supposed to be a guy that was going to
get us into a war in the first week
remember that
where's the war we're taking them out of
afghanistan we're almost finished with
that
working along well there we're taking
them out of syria other than i left some
behind for the oil we kept the oil is it
okay that we kept the uh
could be illegal okay we kept the uh
let's go back to my poll ready so
we're putting i think it should be a
woman
because i actually like women much more
than i like men i have to say
okay no i do
i do i like women more so i have to make
a decision
to fill the seat as we say we should
have a new campaign
let's make a t-shirt fill the seat okay
what my people are so good tomorrow
it'll be all over the place phil
yeah that's a good idea
that's a good that's a good idea fill
the seat
okay watch this so good tomorrow you see
them all over the place fill this in
i don't know how the hell they do it but
they get it done fan remember i said
where's hunter where's hunter the next
day it was like one of the biggest
selling
t-shirts really stupid t-shirt what the
hell ever happened he took the money and
he ran i think
where's hunter he took the money free
word association can't stick to one
topic
he's trying to get back to something he
branched off of ten minutes ago have a
job
until this guy became vice president
then he went to china got 1.5 billion
dollars i asked the head of a great
company blackstone one of the biggest in
the world
black stuff he said steve let me ask you
a question is that possible now that
never is
never done china doesn't do that well
how did a guy with no experience
do this he said very simple his father's
vice president is that what you want
and then and then ukraine 183 thousand
dollars a month
and a three million dollar upfront
payment for him and his friends think of
this
with no experience and no job and they
said do you know energy it's an energy
company that paid it
do you know energy no i don't i've uh
not familiar with the subject right
a great congressman right how the hell
does this happen
i think it'll be brought up in the
debate i think
okay where's hunter where is hunter
you know where hunter is he's probably
in the riviera having a very good time
he's given some great energy advice he's
learning he's taking a night class on
energy for 180
where is hunter corrupt remember joe
with the prosecutor
one billion dollars i'm not giving it to
him until they get those prosecutors
away from my uh
98 of the audience has no idea what he's
talking about
one billion dollars i'm not giving it
you get them out and guess what they got
them out
here's your billion dollars now that's
called quid
pro quo right that's the real deal
with us there was none they made it up
remember when schiff made the phony
speech
eight times he said the same thing the
speech was fake it wasn't really a
speech it was actually a musical
wonderful people that write every
perfect word every word oh i'm glad we
had them because we're dealing with a
bunch of
thieving bad people so women
and men ready would you rather have a
woman in the super
supreme court or would you rather have a
man ready a woman or a man so
would you rather have me choose oh my
god
this very scientific poll actually it's
a lot more accurate than these polls
that interview like
97 people have been interviewed then you
know they charge you a million dollars
and they probably don't interview the
people they sit behind their desk and
just
would you rather have a woman
on the supreme court yes woman yes
this might not go well for me tom tiller
says yes
so would you rather win or would you
rather have a man on the supreme court
[Applause]
what's going on this is so idiotic
let's give it one more quick chance this
is a free paul
this fall and this is a lot of people
this is tens of thousands of people
there's a lot of people
you know the fake news they'll say he
had a smattering of people
you know there are not tens of thousands
of people there tens of thousands would
mean at least twenty thousand there are
not twenty thousand people there
times bigger than bernie's and they'll
say here's a smattering of people
there were people they were in the
middle of an airport that nobody ever
heard of right here we are
thousands if they if those people come
on bring them over what the hell at this
point
might as well let them come on over come
on yeah thousands of people behind these
people i would imagine the sight lines
aren't too good you have stands in front
okay so one more time who would rather
have a man
on the supreme court
boy interesting way of choosing right i
mean
let a random crowd cheer
now tomorrow like fake news cnn
he was playing games with the united
states okay
it is a terrible thing he's done no i'm
just taking a poll
please and by the way that's a very
accurate focus that's the way i feel
it will be a woman a very talented very
brilliant
woman
who i haven't chosen yet but we have
numerous women on the list
i built this incredible list of
brilliant people
and uh we're asking for biden's list he
can't give it you know why
because if he ever gave a list he'd
either put somebody in the left
why would you create a list joe the idea
of creating lists of people
is is actually not that sensible it
doesn't make it why would joe biden give
him a list
he loses his entire left coast right and
if he loses the left coast that's the
end of his election
and last time remember how many people i
got from bernie because of trade
a lot of the bernie people vote for us
because bernie's right about one thing
trade
but bernie took a bad defeat didn't he
it was a bad loss
he's one of the most gracious losers
i've ever seen he is
all elizabeth warren pocahontas had to
do is leave
if she left before super tuesday bernie
would have won every one of those states
but they split up that vote that's too
bad but we have uh sleepy joe
we'll see how that works out i think
it's working out pretty good
you know we were winning so much we
didn't even have we could have called
off the election we were winning by so
much
and then the plague came in from china
and in many ways i had to go back to
work but i had